my fellow fox news primetime host tammy
bruce is here tammy this is a terrible
subject to be
talking about uh on uh on an
independence
day weekend it should surely
shame i don't want to be political about
it but these
cities have been democrat cities now for
90 years nobody remembers what it was
like
when there was anything other but a
one-party state running these
appalling cities
yes and and i think it's perfectly
appropriate to talk about politics uh on
the day and the few days surrounding the
origination of this country which was an
extremely political act
obviously and this is about our keeping
in mind what the founders
wanted and and representing them which
means believing
that every single american no matter
what city they live in
deserves to be able to have a future
which is what the entire revolution was
about was determining our own
futures and now what we've got is a
political system
driven by democrats that have denied
that future to
children to babies to young people
effectively because they've been
corralled into the urban areas
and are controlled by a single party
that is the antithesis of what the
revolution
wanted and was meant for what the
founders wanted
and may i say for teo and for everyone
else who is who is a
anti-violence entrepreneur someone who
can move into those cities
and understands their communities the
fact is
government and politicians like lori
lightfoot now rely
on fear this is about yes violence is a
factor of that
but violence creates a fear that keeps
people in retreat
and it suits them and you know this mark
when she blames
racism and sexism when it's all about
her
when it's about those people uh who are
suffering every single day
in that great american city and shame on
her and everyone in the democrat party
who's facilitating this
i don't know how the families of those
two little girls fighting for their
lives in hospitals
uh aren't entirely sick and insulted
by her reaching for those lamest of lame
tropes you know
uh the left talk about other rising all
the time other rising oh
you're other rising muslims i'm
otherwising transgenders
uh but there's nothing more basic
in terms of other rising than being so
desensitized to your fellow humanity
that you
open fire and you don't care whether you
kill kids
i mean that's once you're once you're at
that stage how do you get
how do these guys it's nothing political
how do you get pulled back from that
see but that's exactly the nature of
what happens when there are no
repercussions
when you've got and it's not even a
passivity it is a decision
to sit back and allow it and when you
receive even subconsciously the message
that this is not no one's going to care
no one's going to come and stop me
that laws really do send a signal about
what's appropriate in a community
and if you want racism and sexism for
lori lightfoot whom i god forbid
thought she she ran as a reformer i
thought she might be
the person to do this and as a gay woman
on top of it
uh to to be in this position where this
city is a river of blood
and all she can do is talk about other
rising
refuse interviews with white reporters
as she goes home to her white partner
she creates this as a race framework
when when you're dead the color of your
skin is meaningless
your children is your or your children
your constituents citizens
all of this has got to stop but it's
people like lori lightfoot
and the democratic party who have a
macabre
ghoulish interest in fear and violence
is a mechanism of that
thank you for that uh tammy and you're
quite right about that disgraceful uh
mayor happy uh happy post independence
day to you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else